i'm gonna say something that is probably
really bad to say considering i'm a
business coach and i and i'm and i teach
people you know with courses and things
every day but we have an epidemic of
people just wanting to learn more and
not actually do things there has to be
this act of doing and what we think is
if i learn all the things the doing will
be easier and that's never the way it
goes
welcome to the think media podcast my
name is heather torres the host of this
show and we are here to help you build
your influence on youtube and then turn
that influence into a high impact and a
high profit online business and today
you are in for a treat we have none
other than my friend jennifer allwood
jen's going to be walking through so
much about how to build your impact and
your income with your online business
especially in the world that we're in
right now there's no better time to be
making income online but first if you're
new to this show we want to welcome you
and say thank you for being a part of
what we're doing here at think media if
you've not yet watched our free youtube
class that would be your next step after
today's episode you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com
because this episode is brought to you
by our free youtube class this is where
you can learn some of the success
secrets to youtube how to get started
and how to scale your youtube channel
and some of the mistakes that youtubers
are making right now that are hindering
their growth we want to make sure you've
got all that information and make sure
you take our free class at
thinkmasterclass.com
alright well today we are going into how
to create multiple streams of income or
how to make extra cash on the side with
your full-time job if you are someone
who has been trying to figure out how to
crack the code like how do i actually
get started what are some ways that
people are making money online and how
can i do it too
jennifer allwood is your girl she's a
midwestern entrepreneur she's a
podcaster author speaker and jennifer
teaches women how to build their
businesses online and that's key for
this episode because her past is an
offline business that she was able to
bring online jennifer helps create
business owners reaching six figures
seven figures and beyond and she's grown
her platform on social media with over a
half a million followers so lean into
today's episode and let's get started
well jen i'm excited to finally have you
on the podcast thank you so much for
making time for us here at the media
heather i will always make time for you
thank you so much for having me i'm
super excited well you know think media
i love to bring experts to you that have
a wealth of knowledge and a depth in one
area and today we're going to be talking
about multiple streams of income i've
brought my friend jen um who i've
actually seen her business grow over the
past several years from helping mostly
women in this area and jen i'm excited
to really break this down for our
community because as content creators we
want to be creating these multiple
streams of income and it's important
that especially content creators and
people that are starting their youtube
channels that they're putting on those
business hats right and that they're
understanding that there is a world of
income available to them in the online
space specifically and that's what you
teach but i'd love to take it back to
the beginning how did you even get
started in building online specific
income streams in your life sure so i
actually and by the way thank you again
heather so much for having me and
trusting me with your audience i'm
excited to be here so i actually started
a business back in the year 2000 my
degree is in computer-based information
systems which was totally a lame
selection i will just say that of
degrees only because not because it's
not a good um thing to choose but i hate
computers but in my head i was like i
want to pick something that i make a lot
of money at not because um i had
you know this greedy heart but because i
know that if i make more i can impact
more if i make more i can give more you
know i can hire more people all the
things i innately knew that so i picked
computers back in the year um 2000 when
i was finishing my degree as a grown-up
and right after that started a
decorative painting company in kansas
city which you're way too young to know
what faux finishing and decorative
painting is but um we were on like the
extreme home makeover show with ty
pennington do you remember that show
heather the move the bus show obsessed
with type headings back in the day yes
done that three times been in countless
magazines flown to belize with my
husband to look at a painting project
there my painting business was
phenomenal but we had gotten to a point
where i knew i was capped on how much
revenue i could make and i can remember
having a service-based company locally
in kansas city where we live me looking
at my checkbook going i'm working way
too stinking hard like there should be
more money there and again not from a
place of greed just from a like lord why
is everything feeling off balance and so
it was in the year 2017 i was at a job
site i had eight women out painting for
me you know everything looked like we
were on top of the world where i thought
to myself there just there has to be a
better way and in my head the only thing
i could think of is how can i teach
people how to do online what i'm doing
locally and so i didn't really know what
i was doing heather um and you know a
lot of entrepreneurs they they delay
because they don't know what they're
doing uh but a lot of times when i don't
know what to do i kind of tend to run in
there anyway because i'm like you know
what what do i have to lose no i don't
know what i do but i bet that i'll
figure some things out as i go so i
started with some like diy painting
videos and i was not on youtube by the
way i was doing
horrible videos with my 12 year old son
noah videotaping me on a client's
driveway painting their garage doors it
was the
worst office video of all time we made
like ten thousand dollars in this video
in a nanosecond and i was like wait a
second and we made a hundred grand on
really bad diy videos back in 2017 in
the first 14 months and that's when i
was hooked to the online space and it
occurred to me okay people buy a diy
video what else will they buy from me so
then i did a webinar and that was when a
lot of people were doing free webinars
and i was like yeah i don't really want
to do free i give away free stuff all
the time i give away free advice i give
freeways stuff on social media i have
opt-ins like i don't want to do free so
i did you know a 47 webinar made 40
grand you know for one night's work and
i was like okay this is amazing what
else could i do so then i released a
course which i still have that we
released twice a year then a paid
membership that is what forbes has done
an article on me about it um
hit a million dollar a year revenue
stream for me four years ago for a 47 a
month membership so um i pivoted out of
the service based painting industry out
of that creative business that i loved
into coaching and teaching other people
how to use social media to make money in
the online space and as you've alluded
to there's just so many different ways
of making money online so i like to
teach about my favorite eight and so we
closed down the painting company in the
year 2017 and here we are so okay a few
different takeaways think media uh that
i want you to write down right now
because this is a conversation you need
to be leaning into because jen's gonna
bring some fire when it comes to the
exact revenue streams you should be
doing but here's a couple things you
said jen you didn't overthink it and man
isn't that just something that we tend
to do way too often like should i do
this or should i do that should i do
this should i do that and then you wait
a year and you haven't done anything yet
well it's but here's why people do it
heather because i think that um it's
important to recognize that we do it but
then we got to figure out well why do i
do do it and the reason we do do it is
because we're afraid of if i pick this
and i'm wrong that's going to hurt and
be painful and costly if i pick this and
i'm wrong well that could be painful and
hurtful and costly and a lot of times
what i've noticed also
is that women who have gone through a
lot of traumatic experiences in their
life
will think to themselves okay i'll do
anything to avoid more pain so i will
innately just kind of stay with you know
what i'm doing as a way to self-protect
rather than pick either and we'll try to
hedge our bets and think okay if i can
think of every single thing that could
possibly go wrong or right with a course
okay and then let me think of every
single thing that could possibly go
wrong or right with you know a
membership and then like let me weigh it
out and let me do a you know pros and
cons list and then if i have all of the
information i'll be able to pick the
right thing that won't fail and the
truth is there's just no like there's no
limits test for that there literally is
no guarantee there is no way of knowing
and we think if i just learn a little
more if i just learn a little more
i'm going to say something that is
probably
really bad to say considering i'm a
business coach and i and i'm and i teach
people you know with courses and things
every day but we have an epidemic of
people just wanting to learn more and
not actually do things
and um and you know that i love jesus um
you know and so the bible even talks
about like faith that works is dead like
there's got to be a doing when we get to
heaven we want to hear well done
good and faithful servant not like well
intentions on that thing
you know what i'm saying and so there
has to be this act of doing and what we
think is if i learn all the things the
doing will be easier and that's never
the way it goes every time we launch
something and we've been launching
courses heather and you know we have a
million dollar course launch every year
we have a million dollar membership um
you know every year so so we've got
we've been doing this for a hot minute
there's still things that go sideways
things that we learn things that we wish
we had figured out beforehand things
there was no way of seeing and so i
think people think if i just figure out
all the things first i'll get it all
right and that's literally not true you
know when i think about you and i both
have a lot of kids how many kids do we
have between the two of us we have a
whole gang yeah we i mean we definitely
got like a football team because you've
got four and i have three so we are we
are basketball i was thinking you had
four maybe you'll have another and jen
i'm here for it i've got the baby fever
so
um so you know the thing is like when
when we had children and there was no
part of me that ever looked at my son
though it was like i cannot believe he
does not know how to walk when he's
trying to learn a lot like
i can't believe he doesn't just know how
to do this and doesn't fall down the
first time he does it like the way that
you learn is to like stumble kind of
muddle your way through things and then
all of a sudden you're like okay this
isn't bad you know and then you've got
it the same thing is happens in business
we expect so much out of ourselves like
i should know how to launch this thing i
should know how to do all the videos i
should know but the way that you
literally learn so often is by going
through it and i know you've got a lot
of creative brains here same total
creative background very chaotic
creative also menopausal mind let me
just say that so there's a lot of chaos
in here and so
literally i have to actually do in order
to learn and i think a lot of creative
people are wired in that same way but
they think if i just know more before i
try it i'll do better and you're
actually going to do so much better to
just try it and learn as you go that was
a lot of words man that was a lot of
words that was that was so incredible
and you know you touched on uh the part
that man i just wish there was more
freedom for people because we go into
things thinking what if this fails like
we've been programmed to just always
think well what if this fails and i want
to shift that mindset especially for you
think media what if this succeeds like
what are the possibilities on the other
side of just taking massive imperfect
action and that's the second thing i
want to touch on that you said is that
you didn't it was not perfect it was
like jankety videos
no microphone like no lighting no
professional this is not the cute studio
uh space that you have at this very
moment it would and yours your your
child was filming you can can i give you
just a few more like details about that
video because it was so bad heather so i
live in kansas city do you guys have
cicadas where you live anybody that's
from the midwest will know what a cicada
is those buzzy things yes and and they
scream in the summer okay so it was in
the summer we were getting ready to take
our family vacation and so i thought to
myself i'm really pale we are pale
people in my family let me go get a
spray tan the day that i decide my 12
year old noah was gonna film a video for
me so i just want you to imagine i i'm
painting garage doors to look like wood
there was there was no this it was a
camera on a very bad tripod that i
probably you know got it target or
something and and my 12 year olds you
know filming me on the camera the
cicadas are screaming because the house
was a new construction right next to a
field it's the middle of summer in
kansas city so that we've got all this
background noise and i am orange from a
spray tan i mean just orange from the
spray tan so i'm orange there's bad
noise it's 10 minutes long i kid you not
10 minutes long and we made 10 000 on
that video because what was important
you know the aesthetics came later we
figured out later how to get things to
be better but what was important in the
beginning was getting it out there and
there was meat and potatoes in that
content i mean i could say i could teach
a lot in 10 minutes and so people kept
coming back for more not because i had
it all fancy in the beginning because
they were actually getting something out
of it and then later we're like okay we
really gotta up our game a little bit um
but you know and so when we knew better
we did better but in the beginning i
just needed to get it out the door and
you know i heard on a podcast one time i
don't know who to credit this line to
but she said you've got to get so okay
with doing b minus work we think we've
got to put out a plus work all the time
and you've got to be okay with getting b
minus work out the door just to get it
out the door because there's something
that happens heather when you start when
you start the ball rolling when you
actually get a little bit of momentum
and you actually figure a few things out
you walk a little different you act a
little different because it's in that
not knowing and that spiraling in the
beginning of well i want to do a video
but i don't know how to do the video if
i don't know how to do the video then i
could launch the vid if that will lead
you to like so much of an unsettled
place internally that if you'll just
start and be okay with it not being
perfect you would be amazed hey the
results that you can help other people
get be how you will actually possibly
enjoy the process you know even if it's
not perfect and see it can really lead
you to like having all these aha moments
of well maybe i don't want to do videos
anyway maybe i'd really rather just do a
course and do it live i mean it's
interesting that as you're doing the
work and getting it out there you will
figure out what you like what you don't
like um what's good enough what what do
you no longer have to worry about but
you have to actually start
man i hope you are getting value out of
this already because i already am i'm
taking notes as we're doing this jen and
i want to pivot a little bit because i
mean there's there's no avoiding where
we are heading in terms of financially
inside of this country and really the
world and and i also say that with the
expectation of the amount of
possibilities that we are heading into
100
into this world and especially in the
online space which is where you are are
truly an expert at jen and so i want to
i want to really talk around you know
how would someone even get started let's
say they've started their youtube
channel already they're making some
videos they're in they they know what
niche they're in right they know who
they're serving they know they know um
you know the types of free videos that
they want to be making how does someone
then pivot into starting to make money
with this beyond just adsense and
affiliate marketing what are just some
of the things that you teach your
community of getting started with this
online space that really allows for
freedom to happen that we'll talk about
in just a little bit so i do teach on
eight different ways of making money and
like you said affiliate income is one
sponsored content is one um courses is
so good for people that like a short
burst of things and they don't want to
have um commitment for a long period of
time with a membership group a paid
membership group which i have there is a
commitment i've had my membership group
for six and a half years and if you're
not someone who likes that sort of
stability and you know
expectations of you every single week i
wouldn't suggest that but there's also
consulting so i think it's number one
figuring out what is a good fit for you
what is also the lowest hanging fruit
that would be a good fit for you because
what you need in the beginning is you
need a win
you know you just need a win and it's
scary when you go from free to now i'm
going to charge and there's a couple
different things so i have a book called
fear is not the boss of you if you
happen to have read it you'll remember
this story when i first decided to start
charging people in the online space i
told a friend of mine and she was like
well is anybody gonna buy from you
because haven't you been giving them
free information this whole time
and i was like oh my gosh
she's right i mean i'm such an idiot
this is stupid i'm stupid the whole
thing's stupid you know maybe i should
just pause
forgetting the a she's not online at all
b she has no idea about what's possible
in the online space at least back then
see there are certain people that you
can't tell your dreams to because
they're dream crushers simply because
they're stuck they don't know what
options they have they think they're
trying to protect you there's a whole
lot there so anyway in the beginning i
was like will anybody actually buy this
i don't know i have been giving stuff
away for so long but what people
actually will pay you for is they will
pay you for having something organized
because the truth is
a lot of the things that i teach like in
my courses you could find everywhere on
the internet heather you could find jen
did a podcast on that once this was in
her book this is in you know on youtube
over here she did a instagram reel over
here and you could kind of put it
together but people will pay for things
to be in a chronological order for it to
be organized well for there to be a
leader for them to have access to you
etc so figure out the vehicle that you
want to put the paid thing in is it
going to be a course a group all the
things you know that i have a quiz for
your audience that i can tell them about
whenever you want me to but that will be
helpful and then the truth is is you've
got to get okay with actually charging
money for something and you know uh
there's a lot of scriptures that will
defend that like a man is worth his
wages and a man that does not take care
of his family is worse than a heathen
and so um and that could be man or woman
by the way and so you know we all have
families to feed or ourselves to feed it
is a mindset shift that has to happen to
go from free to paid and the truth of
the matter is if you don't get okay with
like i'm gonna actually charge for this
i may not know all the things but i know
a few things and i know a few things
more than the people who are coming up
behind me and it's worth them paying me
for those things by the way and so if
you don't get really comfortable with
that your audience can smell it a mile
away they literally can and so you've
got to be okay going you know what i've
given you guys so much value if you love
this
listen to this course that i'm launching
on monday or i would love to invite you
into my paid group or i would love to
get you signed up for a one-on-one
consultation with me here's my candy
link where you can go sign up but you've
got to get okay with actually charging
before your audience is ever going to be
okay with it
wow so many golden nuggets there and i
want to let you guys know the uh think
media community that uh we actually
partnered with a course creating company
and i did an entire series of how to
launch your course in a weekend so if
it's on online and it but here's the
thing it is nowhere near in depth of
what jen teaches so if you just want the
beginnings of like how to name your
course and and you know where to host
your course i can help you with that jen
goes so deep in being able to tell you
the exact step-by-step process of what
she's done and and other and seven other
ways right of how to actually be
creating it jen i'd love for you to tell
the community now uh about this
personality test because with eight
different ways so first off i i had two
emotions with that i was like eight ways
yes and then i was like eight ways oh
gosh which one do i choose so how do
they choose and what is that okay well
so you choose based on and and it is
it's a really it's at jennifer
allwood.com
quiz um just my name slash quiz it's
super easy and if you have time to be on
facebook and take one of those which
disney princess am i most like quizzes
then you definitely have time to go take
this one it's fast and it's gonna ask
you questions like are you good at
taking photos or not
are you good at writing or are you good
at speaking
do you like commitment or do you like to
fly by the seat of your pants are you an
introvert or an extrovert like all of
those things kind of go into what would
be the best thing for you to launch
first because if you're someone that
needs an
influx of cash really fast let's just
say that and you want to be kind of one
and done and you don't love commitment
then do a course if you're like no i
really need the steady reliability of
knowing how much money my company
company's gonna bring in every single
month so i don't have to worry about it
then i would shift you to a membership
like there's so many things like that
i'll have people come to me and they're
like i think i should start a blog and
i'm like why well i heard you can make a
lot of money with the blog okay i beg to
differ and i i hate to like discourage
people but if if you need cash i would
never suggest you start with a blog
today why because in order to make money
off a blog you have to have traffic and
if you haven't started your social
medias and you haven't started your blog
where are you going to get the traffic
from people don't magically find you so
like there's a lot of questions like
that that will lead you into um what is
your lowest hanging fruit what could you
launch the quickest based on with what
your personality is and what you already
have and start there it's just a good
place to start what people do heather
is they um
i'm saying these words all the time you
can tell my age they fiddle fart around
they dick jack around and they're like i
don't know should i do this or this and
then six months go by i'm thinking this
but i don't know maybe that and then
another year goes by and then we've
missed the window i literally did a
podcast episode one time called don't
miss the window because i felt like so
impressed upon me by the lord like there
is an open heaven over
online businesses right now and and so
if you will just get in the game like
people are staring at their phones more
than ever the pandemic was you know so
horrible in so many ways and you know
was awful for a lot of small business
owners with
brick and mortars but it was fabulous
for people who are in the online space
education selling entertainment selling
art classes selling whatever it was so
good for people that had a way of making
money in the online space and so you
know based on where our economy
currently is you kind of you know said
something about that like get in the
game today
one and there's you know there's very
few things on the side of heaven that
are permanent decisions
deciding that you're going to launch a
course is not one of them so you launch
the course you hate it you're like i'm a
knucklehead jen was an idiot for telling
me you know i hated every second of that
that's okay now you know what you don't
want to do again but at least now you've
tried that thing and it will lead you to
the thing that you actually should be
doing
yes yes yes i oh man i'm fired up i'm
gonna say that after every time
someone's gonna comment in the comments
actually they're gonna be like does
heather only say she's fired up yes i do
because i get so passionate
especially around powerful women who are
speaking truth and light and you know
one of the reasons jen that you teach
eight different ways is because you
should have some diversification i know
that there there's definitely uh two
camps right there's the like go all in
on one thing put all your eggs in one
basket i am not of that camp i am of the
camp of building multiple streams and
actually at think media we did a podcast
of 21 revenue streams that we're a part
of that are diversifying our entire
income into the uh the overall business
that we've built because if if one like
if it's if it's three legs on a stool
and one leg goes out you could tip you
could tipple topple over and especially
as we learned a few years ago it could
all be taken away like that your actual
income could be taken away so can you
talk to our audience a little bit about
why they should be diversifying and
building eight plus different revenue
streams in their business in life
actually okay so number one it's
biblical so um in the bible ecclesiastes
11 2 talks about seven yes even eight
ways of bringing money into the
storehouse so it's biblical number two
it's googleable so if you google like
how many if it's not biblical googleable
i love that in the bible meetup i'm like
huh
so you know if you go to google and say
how many revenue streams does the
average millionaire have it's i think
seven um and so and we have eight and i
teach eight okay so here's what happens
though sometimes heather is people will
be like i gotta get all eight at once no
actually go here get good at this one
and then when you get good at that one
you figure it out and you're making
enough money that you have people to
help you you have the time the capacity
then you add the next one then you add
the next one then you add the next one
and so um i had my facebook page shut
down a few years ago i don't think i
knew you then did i mm-hmm
oh man did i have to learn a hard lesson
that week so i'm literally just it was
back when i still had a painting
companies who would have been at least
five years ago
and one of my friends is like why can't
i find your facebook page and i'm like i
don't know now i have a really you know
substantial size facebook page i have
370 000 followers on facebook i've been
verified for years and so when my
facebook page went sideways i'm like
this is going to be a problem
i don't know what i did wrong still i'm
not certain what i did wrong but
basically just three days later it
magically reappeared okay so that was
fabulous but what those three days
taught me is jennifer don't ever put all
of your eggs in any one basket not one
social media and not one way of making
money so that's when i really started
realizing okay the power of a strong
email list the power of two social media
so that if one goes sideways and you
make it oops here that you have another
one to fall back on um the same thing
happens though with revenue streams so i
know so many people who have gone all in
with you know affiliate marketing or
network marketing with a particular
company that company folds that company
goes sideways and then they're left with
no business at all they're left with
revenue overnight and then you're in
trouble and so i'm not anti-affiliate
marketing i do affiliate marketing i'm
not anti-network marketing i've done
that before i am anti like putting all
of your eggs in one basket because i
think one of the things is freedom is
super important to me and for a lot of
reasons and so financial freedom is part
of that and i think it's wisdom that
whatever god has given you to steward on
this side of heaven that you protect it
almost and insulate it almost with other
revenue streams so you know the other
thing heather is like i'm getting a
little older i'm much much older than
you honey so i just turned 51 last week
and as a woman who's getting older i
don't want to have to be doing things
because i have to be doing things in
another 15 20 years do you know what i
mean
i've got to put some revenue streams in
place now that are not dependent on
jennifer being forward-facing um they're
not dependent on you know my team having
to have me to show up in order for those
to happen so we've got like i own a va
service for instance i have talked about
that those sorts of things it's another
revenue stream that's not completely
dependent upon me that would also be
very sellable down the road and so it's
wisdom just to have money coming in in
more than one way just like it is to
like invest your money you know in more
than one way some in real estate some in
stock markets some in the bank you know
it's just it's wisdom and um and so
start with what's going to be the lowest
hanging fruit where you're going to get
some results and then as you figure
things out start adding other revenue
streams on top of that
yeah and you touched on it a little bit
there and i want to go just a little bit
deeper because for me this was this was
why i started building the way i built
meaning the reason i went the online
space versus like should i should i do
brick and mortar should i do you know
should i um have a business that
requires me to actually be somewhere i
saw the vision of what the online space
could do and i'm just incredibly
grateful for that i know that that's
when you made that pivot from your
painting company where you had to
physically be there in kansas city
and actually do client after client
after client um shifting into that
online space i just want people to
understand when we say freedom we're not
talking like we're riding in private
jets and sipping lattes like it's
freedom because of things that have
happened in your life where luckily
because you had those residual income
streams you've been able to consistently
have revenue in your business and into
your family while those things are
happening would you mind sharing just
maybe i would love to because i think
this is a big piece for people of even
understanding why shifting online is so
critical especially in what's to come in
the future so one of the things that i
realized when back when i um was
operating my painting company is number
one i told you like i knew i had capped
our income and by the way it was several
it was multi-six figures a year with me
working outside of the home like 10 to
15 hours a week because i had a team of
women that worked for me so it probably
looked ludicrous to the world for me to
shut that down um and i did the coaching
and that for a while but it eventually
became so obvious to me that there is so
much more opportunity for growth over
here than what there is over here
what um some a couple of little things
happen number one it became obvious to
me okay wait a second i got called for
jury duty while i have to go to jury
duty oh my gosh how am i going to make
money like you know in the painting
company because i'm like if i can't
physically be there i or have the girls
there working then we're not making
money you know and then i've got aging
parents okay what if i need to stay home
with aging parents like how are we going
to make money if i'm not physically
working and as a creative you know a
creator maker that had to work with my
hands or have other women doing it for
me like i had to almost be present
in order for that to keep going so it
became obvious to me like that is not
what i want to do long term i don't want
to be tied down to not being able to
travel i don't want to have set hours a
day you know i think that there's
something interesting heather about
people that are really wired for
entrepreneurship a lot of us we just
don't like like the norms or rules it's
like it's like that movie divergent do
you remember that i love that movie so
much we just watched it again when we
were um we have a second home in florida
so we were at our second home floor this
week and the kids never watch it it's
like we don't fit into a box yeah and so
if you know if you really
want to have freedom you're gonna have
to position your business in the freeze
place on the planet which is gonna be in
the online space and even if you're like
oh but i don't like social media oh but
i don't like whatever well you're gonna
have to figure out which would you
rather have because if you really want
the freedom that being an entrepreneur
in online space can provide for you both
financially and in your time
then you're gonna have to just decide
well how can you then build something in
online space and either get help for it
or what have you but i knew that we
wanted to travel i knew that we wanted
to do things like adopt a child which by
the way is not free um i knew that we
wanted to be able to have the option for
our children to go to different schools
if we wanted to all of that was going to
require funds we wanted to be able to
support ministries that we love et
cetera and so you know i think you get
to a point where you're like am i super
just uncomfortable with where i
currently am because sometimes you get
to a point of just you're so
uncomfortable that then you're willing
to make this shift and i wasn't there
i was more in the point that i was like
ah this is really beginning to be a drag
over here and i just see incredible
opportunity over here in the online
space so again that was back in 2017
what i've noticed that people though are
doing today is this is how they protect
themselves from doing big hard and scary
things
or the markets saturated there's so many
people already doing it what could i add
new to the conversation et cetera et
cetera and and i'm just i'm going to
tell you because i love you it's such a
lie from the pit of hell because that is
how it's easier to say the market is
saturated than to go in and try to
launch a course or offer consulting or
get paid to do social media you know
have ads on your website whatever that
all feels super vulnerable and so you
know
doing something you've never done will
always require a level of vulnerability
that you probably don't want to
volunteer for but the truth of the
matter is you're going to have to and on
the other side of being vulnerable is
the opportunity to take your business to
whatever level that you want for it to
we went from a 500 000 a year business
to a 2 million business in like a 10 day
period 5 years ago and and i and i still
like it changed our whole life we were
able then for my husband to quit
corporate america we adopted a little
girl we've you know uh remodeled this
home we bought another home we bought a
home for his parents like when you are
willing to be like okay i don't know
what i'm doing
this feels very awkward feels a little
bit like i'm standing on the internet
naked we're gonna go for it anyway like
when you're willing to do that it is
amazing the doors that will open up and
the opportunities that you will be able
to rise to the occasion for which can
change your whole life and the whole
trajectory of your family and it's never
just about us can i just say one more
thing you can
there's so many people that are like oh
i'm so afraid to grow my business okay
but what about that girl that's sitting
at home right now that she needs a
part-time job that you could offer to
her if you would just have the guts to
start building that business that god
has given you the idea for but you're
sucking your thumb in a corner because
it's scary listen we're all scared so
get in the game do it scared do it with
your thumb in your mouth if you need to
there are so many wonderful people like
you heather like me who will well like
arms with people and and you know do the
ride with them but there's just in 2022
you have got to have a way of making
money that is not requiring a physical
location in my opinion number two it's
not dependent on you getting a check
from someone else that is false security
we think oh it's so much safer to work
for an organization no it's not i've
been laid off my husband's been laid off
so that is false security
bet on yourself bet on yourself every
single day of the week there is so much
opportunity in the online space there's
so much room here and so whatever gifts
that god has given you figure out how to
monetize them get in the online space
get on social media start putting things
up for sale bada boom
this conversation has been again i'm on
fire i'm so i hope that you are
encouraged think media um i want you to
take the quiz if if your next face like
what should you do next you should take
the quiz to figure out your revenue
streams you should figure out what the
next thing you should do and then i want
to make a challenge to you get it up get
it going get it moving and start perfect
messy right you've got to just start
messy and it's never going to look the
way you want it to look it's never going
to sound the way you want it to sound um
i remember our when we launched our
first course here at think media we were
just talking about it today on an all
team meeting we said guys what you see
now is not where it started it was
jankety on some slide decks we put it
out there and then we revised it and we
revised it and we revised it we added
another revenue stream we added a thing
you've got to just start messy and so i
want to encourage you to take that quiz
i'll link it down below any resources
that we talked about in this i'll link
jen's book down below make sure you get
a copy of that such an incredible book
um and then i'll link down below the um
the course walkthrough of how to get
your first course started in a weekend
if that's the route for you but i want
you to just take this conversation and
run with it really figure out how you
can break free how you can get freedom
by joining this online space by joining
this this place where you can find the
right people for you think media i know
you're creating content on your youtube
channel but did you know there's an
entire world out there beyond youtube
that's where i want you to go next so
jen thank you so much for this fruitful
conversation thank you for doing the
hard work stepping out of what looked
like a very fruitful season into a space
where you were able to go even bigger um
and i just know that there's gonna be so
many blessings on you and your business
and i just can't wait to see i'm so glad
we've linked arms and i get to be along
the ride uh to see what you're doing um
over in the gen all wood world so thank
you for being a part of heather thank
you so much for having me appreciate you
well i hope your journal is full after
that episode with jennifer allwood and i
am so grateful that she brought her
knowledge and everything here to the
podcast if you want to go deeper we'll
make sure that all the links and the
link to her book are down below in the
description box or in the show notes of
this episode her book is fabulous and i
highly recommend that you get it you
highlight it and you give it to a friend
as well well every single week we love
to be able to see our community come to
life here on the show and that's through
where you rate and review over on apple
podcast we did you know have
international listeners and so this week
is dedicated to our international
friends and family of think media
today's review comes from tdog101578
tdog says always on point shawn and his
team at think marketing which is think
media now uh are always on point leading
the way for creators to stay on top of
their game with new tips and strategies
to keep crushing it on youtube and other
social media platforms i like that the
shawnisms of crushing it is on there as
well
and your latest episode on tips from the
bible is amazing thanks for stepping out
and sharing stories from your life and
sharing the words on your platform i too
am a christian and have recently come
out of a long on and off struggle with
alcohol you've inspired me to stay the
course love you all and appreciate the
work that you do well tdog we want to
just first congratulate you for taking
that step to freedom and we're so
grateful that we get to be a part of
that journey with you stay connected
with us here at think media and your
future will be bright well thank you so
much for being a part of what we're
doing here on this show and we'd love
for you to write and review this show
and leave a comment down below on
youtube and if you know someone who
needs to be creating multiple streams of
income maybe it's your sister maybe it's
your best friend maybe it's your friend
at work who has that idea but hasn't
taken the step to do it i'm gonna
encourage you to share this episode with
them this content can change lives and
it only happens if you share it out so
thank you so much for doing that for us
and we'll catch you in the next episode
bye
[Music]